okay I know that we're just filling up
hard over here and I think I'm disaster
I'm the scientific director for the
Alberta subject for child family and
kind of a research and the interim
scientific director for the strategic
chemical network and maternal newborn
child and youth health so I think today
our first task is to introduce ourselves
to each other and then we'll approach
the question and I think the idea is
we're making few notes on the flip turns
and some he will report back to the
larger group and i'm going to pick on
math here to start to introduce yourself
because
the familiar face you should get us all
going to Jeff hi hi everyone I'm Bev
parks the executive director at Norwood
Child and Family Resource Center but I
also sit on many more of the provincial
collaborative and looking at child and
family and what what we do within the
province of Alberta to to move that
forward anyhow we shift the practice of
what we're doing my duty
to Oman and collaborate
joy hi my name is Lynn Wayne from the
winnipeg stewart association and i
support individuals with developmental
disabilities find employment or
volunteerism on an individual basis I
healthcare build up that social identity
hi I'm Katie boxer I'm a community
social worker with the city of Everton
I'm also supporting the community
well-being working group which is part
of a task force the mayor has to end
poverty and tonight we are looking at
our recommendations or what we will put
forward and draw for mental in as part
is on it so this is amazing
my name is Gigi 3am the chief and
analytics officer at Emerson research we
do what I'm responsible for the center
is to locate two existing data was
research data administrative officers
serve delivery data and we link that to
do research lab I'm daddy Clark on the
executive director of the family
violence help center so we're one of
those innovative service models where
were the one stop shop the first call
the wrap arounds of our of rage
connections for individuals have been
abused and we've been open to her for
about five years I'm the manager and I'm
with RBC so RBC foundation ever gets a
sponsor here I specialize in working
with not for offense so she got very
appropriate for me to be here and it
sure is while hearing about what guys
are up to that's very exciting yes open
up with some good ideas we can get a
business plan but there's no hassle 30
minute awesome so I'll try and take some
notes in between gingy and I will try
and facilitate the conversation but the
questions we've been asked to address
sir what did we learn that's new and
inspiring so maybe we'll start with that
one
start dinner yeah burger well for me
like I am a student of psychology and
the 90s typically back when and it was
really interesting to see that that
change of you know it's not about the
person but about how we relate how we're
tied into our community and see that the
research is around that because you know
we haven't been really successful in
addressing issues of mental illness and
addiction and also you know to see
professor mud room Simon Fraser Bruce
Alexander and I kids worked from like
the 70s actually coming out you know and
you know seeing how important your
environment is to our own personal
health so that was really exciting to
see that some see that being the main
thought you know social identity I'll
just figure out what to measure yeah
for me I wasn't aware of the work in
economics that related to the identity
issues which to me is a gigantic
improvement to ground economics in the
real world because i thought was taught
a long time ago in it had all these
assumptions that weren't real and now it
seems to be grounded I thought the
Economist wanted epidemiologists because
when they put the word actions and
cognition I thought that's right for me
to was the Economist stay
love that he was able to do that because
I've been thinking a lot about narrative
actually and how we create a new a
narrative about the work we do in about
the sector that has sort of applicable
for more than just the postcard with the
child with big eyes on them right how do
we create different narratives or not
excuse me home
so interesting for me I guess it and we
were having a conversation at the break
and it goes back to how we have research
policy and then the practice and how
there's still that disconnect because
when i was looking at this and I'm
thinking okay first of all this is not
new we already know this common sense
tells us from a practical perspective we
already are doing some of this and and
so I don't mean to be the naysayer or
the Challenger but but again it talks
about until the researchers name it put
it out there and show show evidence
which i think is really crucial for sure
do not get me wrong but until we have
that then there isn't the ability to
then talk to the practitioners at that
level and say now how do we bring the
two together and do the learning so
while I there was learning there for me
but I think I'm always inspired when I
see policy and practitioners coming
together to have these discussions
because we don't do enough of that so we
have this level and we have this level
but we're missing what's happening so
that we can work better perhaps
differently or scaling up some of what's
already happening but have the evidence
to address it
just a question are you aware of
instances practitioners have a lien to
the boss sorry we're removing
practitioners have caused the policy
discussion yes so that happens in yeah
remember what I wanted to say
Katie and I were talking about the
Reston where to bev the research of
firms that work that many of us have
been doing for a very long time client
said to a person-centered the words can
changing but we have you been using
these models time so sadly we're still
in a place where in a lot of businesses
where practitioners haven't been
effective in informing policy perhaps a
now that we have this research to go
along with it I think will be very
helpful and also maybe just give you and
I have to be so many meetings together
by Matty but you know I've seen there's
this new language called academia that's
like circulating and maybe it's because
I'm currently working on it applied
research paper but I the question is in
here and I guess I believe this with a
group is that I think that's where we
need to go next like we have good
relationships with some researchers
through community university partnership
or within our sectors we may use to get
together very regularly and now three
orbs of policy seems
not made that happen anymore so I'd be
interested to explore you know some
further questions around not only how
will we applied in our work but you know
what's next as far as connecting that
academia and the practical pieces and
make it applied research like research
that we actually start to apply well I
agree with that one so I hope you'll
send a note to the center saying you
want more funding that way absolutely do
you have any other funding and we need
funding so that would be good for me it
definitely brought to the social
identity sort of thinking like many have
expressed right we we all know the
importance of sense evolving we all know
importance
being part of a bigger hole right we all
know and these things would benefit and
we also want those everybody wants to be
part of a group part of something right
but i think you know if you consider the
next question how you apply actually I
was thinking well the talk was going on
thinking you know how we umpires at our
research probably optimism break up by
age gender Yogi's are groups but they're
so large you do identify you when you're
older unit oh is that but but really you
know can we think about other groups
where you can take a look right without
researching so I think that's very
helpful to me too will now thinking
explicitly about how a subscriber
identity could help to improve
you know I'm just thinking out loud
Shinji when you say that we could map
social identity was measuring because we
would have neighborhood indicators of
things that create identity can we do do
that like this it is a big one right
usually people but you know there are
other things we could to go deeper if we
have about it and used other sources of
data of interact yeah getting into yes
lower levels well I don't know if my
comments are about what's new but I
think the timing is so important so one
of the things that's happening with the
poverty elimination task force's there's
analytics that they're developing where
they can really map oh and just comment
you just mentioned mapping out very
specifics about what what in communities
what helps bring better health so for
instance if you live close to a park
it's been shown that you like within one
kilometer you have better health
outcomes and there's so many different
layers that can connect to that but for
my work with doing community work I just
see the concept of groups and with what
groups you belong to is so critical and
part of what I do is try to connect
different groups together whether it's
social agencies or professional groups
but they sometimes the groups that are
missing are the people who are
experiencing you know the vulnerable
communities because sometimes they're
hard to reach but I've had the great
opportunity through some engagement the
last two weeks with with vulnerable
communities who are feel part of the
organizations that they're connecting to
and it's so inspiring that really what
does matter
I've never kind of had that perspective
you know and such explained so
eloquently as today so it's good to have
the language of it we don't really talk
in that kind of language is for existing
organization night anything like
whenever we do organizations planning or
you know we always identify vision and
we were tracking partland two of the
three whole organization so we all
identify with it and we feel that
camaraderie and we work together towards
the same goal and purpose right so easy
this makes it more transparent so you
can be more intentional and creating
jobs group group processes and recognize
the value in doing them in different
places to whether his research speaks to
you know groups and community
neighborhoods aren't necessarily static
rate they can be changing and evolving
all the time and that whole reflection
piece of just very basic guess it just
it just use them like don't even want
your group to look like it and you know
we do do this right but it was just like
a nice reminder like
just now very appreciated I think the
thing that has been missing and so when
you think about you know how do we apply
this it's not necessarily how do we
apply it as much as it is how do we
apply the research are the evaluative
and the evidence to the work that's
being done because I think that you know
it's also we tend to overstay well we're
already doing that we just this is this
is just affirming that wall we're not
always doing that let's be frank there
are some things that if we paid more
attention to the research or to the
evaluative pace it might change the way
in which you might apply that at a
practical level and so I think for me
what's been even in this last couple
years I think as a practitioner is
taking the research and the
evidence-based and applying that to the
work and then looking at how we can
always be evaluating what we're doing as
we move forward and that's where I think
we're we are going to start to decrease
that gap between the research and
evaluation and the practical and as we
start to do more of that it'll come like
this and it will then become a natural
piece of our working together and
looking at those measures and and how we
do that but I think the other thing
there's some other work that's being
done right now and the research and and
looking at from a family violence
perspective and you probably know about
this Deb and the work out of Calgary and
Brenda Stafford is that and the
Fatherhood piece and how they were
looking at that natural gathering and
how important the natural gathering
groups are to actually form some of that
base in order to move forward and I
think we just need to be paying more
attention and I think we need to be
doing more reading and having more
conversations and asking better
questions we call that in our
intervention integrity it's so it's not
just as we heard having people come
together there has to be there are some
strategies that make groups more
effective that we can measure and I
think when we fail to measure that then
we don't know why some of our
interventions that are supposed to work
don't work and then we haven't the
evidence to say these steps all matter
or some of them mattered more or less
other places you guys will apply it
we're doing in the question of right and
your yes that's right but you can merge
and all its okay behb sort of picked up
because i work in town jobs so of course
I think implying the game you know apply
for we're not going to apply for a job
with this I you know I think it is is
helping have that kind of mind shift in
our culture I think I think it will have
to have some just really candid
discussions about you know what does it
mean our rules is you know thinking
ourselves as helpers and they're the
help right which I think really has a
huge impact on how we value them and I
think we have to get ourselves out of
that they're not people that that this
is not you know these are not people
that need to be helped right we're
thinking about you know the health of
our whole society it's you don't know
what you know and thinking of what them
individually but how they connect out so
for me it is going to be like having
having those discussions so because
again like you were saying we do have a
lot of these person-centered you know
policies and processes in place but are
we still treating people like they're
the helped you know and we're not seeing
them as as very valued value people in
our lives in our communities I think we
heard a little bit of that
the panel and I've also heard it
explained by other economist's about the
need for reciprocity so sense of
belonging doesn't come with it all just
goes out there needs to be intentional
reciprocity if it's a charity case when
you're connecting people to comedians a
charity case it's not it's not going to
be meaningful for either for it's going
to be a little blue situation or
effective look at the impact on the
Aboriginal community it's recolonizing
them we need to really be able to do
things in a way that is respectful yeah
it was interesting along that line I
heard this CBC idea you know that
program and they talked about tolerance
it's interesting and they couldn't
tolerance about you don't we talk about
tolerance because when you talk about
that word dollars is you presume that
these people who are tolerating are
something wrong and different so you
need action taller you know you put
yourself down to that level dealers okay
that's
should I actually gave a historical
definition of tolerance which was the
willingness to not do harm to others
because they are different to you that's
actually technically the definition of
tolerance which was like oh it's
actually Wow like yeah that was a bit of
a mind rap was very interesting again
yes I right now elevate ourselves beyond
that
but to be a really go back to the
original meaning of colors it is just
awareness about when you when you think
about you know how the scituate entity
that word is that you have to be you
know fundamental respect everyone and
really maybe we're all created equal so
without that you know that's why I when
from the coma social identity
perspective in there so he's
in that context of Tolerance it's about
understanding what people's you know how
they actually define themselves how they
see themselves how they interact and I
would I would see that that's how you
would bring a social identity framework
to that to actually understand what
constitutes that person self what are
the factors that are important aspects
of them and how do they actually sort of
try and try and live those aspects out
and that I think will actually
contribute to greater tolerance if you
can understand that person's perspective
from their self-identity perspective
then it's going to set a breach on that
tolerance I think the challenge in
nursery and I just think the challenge
of that in urban centers is that
everybody's you know driving their car
you're not places to go yeah they bring
people together and so there's a visit
is that sort of me a structural yes I'm
the aspects structures yet and to bring
those opportunities and I think that
that sort of question about social
spaces and manageable social spaces
where people can actually come together
safely and want to come together in
those sorts of social places in order to
be able to interact in that way because
there are places where they don't exist
as you said
that's interesting also culture you're
saying it's city planning or lifestyle
kind of thing but salsa culturing when I
come to the Western culture in of one
thing I have to learn is to respect to
you know people's privacy and knowing
that distance and you have to make
appointment before you knock on their
door but that's not true you know in the
culture and I came from so people just
jump I you know they they do things and
and they've never really they really
make themselves at home when they come
so you know sometimes annoying yes there
is that aspect but really it also warms
your heart you think about that you know
you just feel very close to them so you
do have them kind of opportunity but
near Western culture especially those in
our culture I find it's very
individualistic so they're definitely
benefits of that fun to you in terms of
community and interaction I just say in
taking it back and applying it in at the
today center is the the staff and the
clients we see have long been looking
for these different types of ways to
group so so not you know don't read ekta
mais being Andrey traumatized me and you
know send me you know to to those types
of groups but I want to be part of a
group where I could just journal or just
read or just do art and we've had a real
challenge and you know doing that
bridging work as part of our work with
other organizations to kind of bring
that together right and sometimes it's
is taking this language i think is
starting to talk about different place
based approaches and it's sometimes a
boat the structure so you know having
maybe this place in the community that
they could go to you but where can we
look at existing spaces that aren't
thought of right like why couldn't we do
in our group right the day center right
so you know starting to use some of this
language you shared with us under
research
you know supporting some of the
conversation so where we want to go
because being able to you know develop
that group and a group that's supportive
for them and that works and to allow
individuals to group themselves not say
here is this self-help group and it runs
mondays and thursdays at the center
right and start to think about how we
can apply this to allow those processes
for some of the people we're supporting
to group themselves right so once we
hear you know two or three people if
they want to be knitting with
you see how we can innovative and
starting eating group and maybe as an
art center first moves to a community by
using this as the language but what we
want to do is we want to be able to
influence policy right and we want to be
able to to influence practice and so you
can look at that one of a variety of
levels but I think if we're able to say
these are the the practices or the the
models that work and this is why then it
allows people to sink through a
different lens so I think about
Community Planning I think about
transportation I think about housing in
that and if we use that kind of a lens
it really will influence policy so how
you develop a neighborhood how that is a
plan for how you build in whatever the
services are supports that are needed
would be in that neighborhood so that
that would allow those types of things
to happen so so it's right from the
practical letter group or begin to write
up to the higher is we need to use this
as a lands and to help us when we're
looking at how we would develop a new
community out in southeast or we have
60,000 people coming in to Edmonton how
have we really use that lens in the way
in which we apply the development of
these areas so I think that's a piece of
our problem all the way through this is
we're not we're not looking through the
eyes of a child we're not looking
through the eyes of what a family
requires we're not looking through those
eyes of
the social innovation and and that type
believe so I think we can influence
policy in that way if we're applying
more neutral because it doesn't have an
engagement to it it's just about the
practical environmental supports that
help all families and the typical things
that happen so maybe it has less
discrimination associated with the
language than an addict for a
homelessness or a youth at risk or
whatever so maybe that's an easier
marketing tool to know
if you experience that we developed
these community building capacity in
bands or whatever to bring communities
together and no one shows up right like
you think I'm gonna get the same people
right I the same people you had
originally that it was a preaching to
the choir kind of situation and and and
I think about my father who you know I
you know I'm giving all the tablets so
you can have for the senior centers all
the activities you can get involved with
and groups and support groups of this
cancer mobilize like every day he's
going to McDonald's because they got 55
stink off your 65 second coffee means
with the people that gravitates there
along the consequence complaining and
and grumbling about you know younger
generations and I think it's fantastic
and it's old like so organic and just
going to just have it and the funny
thing is that when I was traveling
throughout like the you know down
through southern Alberta in the stage
and up through bc we stopped off at
breakfast or Donald emberia group of old
guys in overrated together yeah that
you're working sometimes yeah well all
over the city yes but how many groups of
women you see like that well there's
some women in is that yeah but not many
there's a kvamme little email yeah for
sure especially in the rural community
had a girl they both come in from the
farm oftener coffee in the morning I
just think you the ones that are ready
to get some
but it's not stigmatizing right and it's
organic as Ben's death and it's a
neutral place and it's affordable and so
it makes me question my intervention you
know and what I do yeah and we try to
enforce artificial reefs on people yeah
so what I guess that message go back to
to the people and say where where are
your groups who are you connected to
like what I did this engagement with the
church in Beverly and they the whole is
three the homeless fellow said our group
is each other are and we have each
other's back tonight and I had no idea I
just assumed that they're all individual
people do it looking out for themselves
and I have a clue and you know key but I
think what's happening is we're not
asking the right questions we're not
asking the right questions so I go back
to what Lynn and you're talking about it
and I don't know who the we is or any of
that but but but it is about imposing
rather than inquiring and then walking
alongside so you know it's it's the
parents or the community members and
they're saying this is what we would
like well we tend to take it over here
instead of empowering them and walking
with them and letting them figure it out
or design or that type of thinking and I
think until we start doing that a little
bit more think that's where we're going
to see some different results because it
just goes back to what we're all saying
we're not the experts right or not we're
just part of
no I just you know I go back to that
word assume anything that's what I'm
kind of hearing we're assuming we think
we know what they want and what they
need like what you say about McDonald's
and I work with a lot of seniors lives
and it's amazing how many little groups
are fair and it's a little ladies
knitting group but they formed it
themselves it wasn't it wasn't organized
but that's what you ladies wanted and
then they take it a step further they go
up to the potty asking for pole I don't
know I've got a good intention give it
and then they need you know the tubes or
the MetService cars and they feel so
good and I think hey Bradley exactly in
with the school's the inner city school
so which is where my daughter works so
it's a circle right and they
self-identify social network there is a
lot of evidence out there in
organizational settings and beyond that
actually showed that that are much
bigger magnet yeah and it has a longer
life as a result so for those can you
sort of facilitating for support and you
know programs and services how do you
find there as a whole yeah and I think
that certainly there's there's
organizations that we've worked with
where they actually try and provide that
facilitation but then transfer some of
their ownership and empower champions
amongst the people who are taking part
to continue working on that on that
dimension so initially people might feel
very uncomfortable they night might not
feel confident in being able to sort of
facilitate these groups but it will
happen and sometimes it does take
facilitation and sometimes it's not
necess
so it's really going to be very much
dependent on their people who are taking
part that people they might not driving
it and obviously as you say not to step
on you know let it let it have a life of
its own I work with a population adults
with developmental disabilities and they
have lived a life being pleasers and not
having any self direction and it's I
find those that are appreciative inquiry
is such I too long endeavor and you have
to be really creative to have some sort
of understanding i don't think a lot of
people put that that investment in time
but it is something that has to i guess
i always use the word organic it has to
spring on its own time appreciate that
they have their own sense of time and
they have their you know but it's yeah i
just might at some time expressing a
real challenge for me because some they
just like well what do you want me to do
you know and then it's tough you know
yeah i've got a lot of great ideas but
you know what you know what is it that
what would
and it guess it's just like being in the
moment every time is seeing when the
face brightens up and that's it it's the
only reliable indicator I feel like I
have it's like wait I'm saying that the
rise that physical rise in their body
I've seen you know that they're they're
doing things that the way you should
apply for they're talking now and I'm
like okay now we got something you know
I'm word with that I was going to ask if
it didn't get a chance so all this you
we didn't mention social media so there
are a lot of groups there so what's the
effect wouldn't that be different from
the traditional sort of social group so
I don't think we have enough evidence
theoretically so a lot about a lot of a
lot of our interventions are being
driven by the theory and the theory
would actually say that look it's the
social connectiveness that's the
important aspect and so it shouldn't
matter what facilitates that social
connectedness it's it's when you
actually feel bonded and connected that
it should actually be the as impact so
theoretically social media should be as
impactful as face-to-face interactions
we haven't got those studies and we're
trying to get some funding to be able to
do some of that research with a
colleague in Kansas and seeing whether
we can actually use social media and
we're actually sort of linking this in
working with older people but they were
living in the community linking it in
with exercise groups and looking at the
group therapeutic component of doing
this in groups versus doing this
individually and doing this through
social media through all of these
interesting apps that people now have to
connect socially even while you're
walking versus doing this face-to-face
because it might be something about okay
if its face to face there might be some
level of intensity some issues about I
identify fast
certainly what we've seen is that when
when when some seniors have identified
faster they got the better cognitive
benefits for some of the interventions
reminiscence interventions that we've
actually run so there might be these
other factors that we're not taking into
account in our morals I want so we need
to test them it would be more about the
personal development of learning how to
use it may have an interaction with a
trainer I thought that would grow use it
to pump them [ __ ] clean all day yeah
it was interesting about your research
is it's not like sec Torrio and it's not
an issue based and I think that's the
challenges for us as practitioners is
when we're looking for that
evidence-based research there's very
little of it because it's done by sector
or my issue so because there has been
some social media research done around
supporting victims and those are our
users with family violence but when you
go and look at it through so few study
and you know even sometimes you look at
the earth and all of you so I think
that's what's so exciting about where
you're going is it's not issue a snot
necessarily place-based but it gives it
gives us that or urging kind of theory
that we can then take and look in our
own mower
and see what we can do so thank you for
that I think it's huge I mean apart from
her spell all of our previous
interventions have been working with
working with organizations who are
basically coming to us and we start
negotiating well we're confronting this
problem how might we deal with it so
we're in a table with with residents
staff and we start negotiating we start
talking about well how might we might we
sort of developed some solution to this
once we're actually working as a group
that time we also have the commitment of
the organization and the staff working
within the organization because they
feel that they've been part of it too so
it's very much being driven by the
ground level problems that people face
and looking for a solution to that
ground level problem and we've just been
very lucky to be able to be working with
a number of organizations who've been
willing to work with us in that way so
Katherine I have a election he had a
question and lots of us here working
with children and you yeah so order the
early childhood intervention that
prevents exclusionary activity by mental
school or grade four that's good
question because that's not where my
expertise comes from I have some
colleagues who are working with a very
privileged group
people who go to what they call churches
in Brisbane and these are kids who come
from very wealthy backgrounds parents of
diplomats it's a it's a living square
boarding school and you would think that
they have they have all of the resources
actually thrown out and despite all of
those resources they're suffering but
because they have resources they
actually came to our department and
talked to a number of researchers social
psychologists who they're now trying to
work collaboratively with to see whether
there are some solutions to some of
their problems and forming social
connections and being disconnected from
where they're sort of standard home
connections are you know like their
friendship networks their family network
hello welcome back everybody lastly I'm
going to invite all the groups to please
come back to the main plenary room and
we'll have a report back so my artist
and I'm hoping that we can kind of latch
onto some of that because they'd be very
keen to see whether we can adapt some of
our solutions that we've been working
with we have adults and older adults to
a younger younger age group I'll be
interested around the parents exactly
don't yell this very capacity and
looking at the types of sessions
education parenting all that that we're
offering and is that where we're seeing
those outcomes or we were allowing them
to be building their own informal social
networks based on their interests what
would those outcomes be
we need to sort of educate people about
how they can actually sort of tap into
those networks and how to use the most
effectively may I think he is calling us
back thank you thank you for the new
okay everybody let's take our seats
we'll have a report back from our six
discussion groups I hope everybody's
nominated somebody to report back on
behalf of your group who's our spokesman
from our spokesperson from group number
one where was Group one over here in the
corner Group one was right here how
about you two okay number two group two
would you like to share some of the
thoughts from your group please well I
have volunteered on behalf of group to
what we learned we said it was evidence
based so it was informative of course we
did recognize the language of us and
them other issues that were raised that
of course is that not everybody is aware
of groups or the groups that they would
belong to so there is the group's piece
as well and if I think it informal as
about thinking what is meaningful in
terms of our work environment as well
the other piece i think is it may not be
applicable to to all groups because some
of them have already been deed if we
think of our indigenous business here
they do have that social identity but
there are so many other that the
challenge service is more complex than
not just belonging to a group
there are historical colonization and
operation and of course on top of that
some of the other things that have been
closed because of those experiences so
the other part a question number two
what will what really apply I think that
we will take you to our groves and we
will share it with with our colleagues
at work and it can be applied in our
informal policies for some of for some
of us so some of the concepts could be
introduced to a group dynamics within
our work environments and that sense of
inclusion of people in programs and want
the whole social inclusion number three
how will you apply it of courses again
sharing it with our colleagues we need
to inform and educate others and maybe
take some of the videos that will be
produced that I think there may be a
video that's produced or use the
scarcity video as well so use some of
the current available resources or
whatever will be produced from here as
well and encourage people to reflect the
work and the policies that they do so it
is about India empowering individual
behaviors within our working
environments as one so this is a summary
of the help have done I think a
combination of knotted room thank you
very much moving on to group three
thanks Amy and I'll just try to
summarize for my group and they will
chime in I'm sure and helped me where I
got it quite right I think one of the
things that was highlighted by our group
was the change from looking at outcomes
from an individual level to an inclusive
group membership level as a metric for
health and we talked about appreciating
the economic emphasis that was brought
to bear a lot of us are in health and
human services and so it broadened our
narrative to think that other people
were also interested in these content
issues gave us some new language we
discussed a little bit about the
research policy practice disconnect and
then bevan our group said really it's a
new frontier for prac ademia which so
practice based research I've heard them
in medicine called pragmatic clinical
trials or whatever and so I think lots
of people are thinking how can we get
better evidence from what we're
currently doing there was some
affirmation that our practice models
actually did include some of the
attributes of social inclusion and
cohesion and we talked about social
identity being more succinctly defined
in terms of both belonging to a group
and then having some responsibility back
to a group so it wasn't just a one-way
street a further comment was that this
was really good timing because lots of
people are preparing year-end reports or
future planning and they'll be able to
incorporate the language and some of our
new analytics we thought we could use to
better understand social identity
without necessarily having to have
primary data collection so that was
exciting for some of the data people in
the group
in terms of application we had quite a
few frontline organizations in our group
and there was a thought that we could
use this intentionally we can map things
we can analyze our data there was some
reassurance that this research really
can be applied to what is intuitively
known in practice and again just gave us
more courage to go forward with some of
the strategies that are already underway
we have some further discussion about
the concept of the helper versus the
helped and I alluded to that in terms of
both responsibility and belonging and so
to be respectfully engaging our our
customers and being aware of social
identity as part of a component of our
frontline practice we've talked a little
bit about how we could apply it in terms
of changing the structure to bring about
new opportunity and incorporating and
understanding cultural differences as
these applied to changes in structure
and I gained some new language around
place based approaches that people
thought they might use and how these
place based approaches could lead to new
models that included things like
transportation community planning and
service and support
I think I'll just end because we had a
few adjacent questions but we thought
some of the application could also
encourage us to ask better questions and
to inquire as opposed to impose when
we're trying to develop some of these
strategies to improve social identity
thanks Suzanne and group number four
ah okay so we had a wide-ranging
discussion one of the big takeaways for
people was that you know of course group
identity is important it's obvious but
we often forget that when we're actually
putting into practice people found it
helpful to sort of learn the the
language of the discipline and know the
terminology that that's being used and
finding it that there's actually this
research backing for intuitive
conclusions that people have come to in
their own practices some of the what
else do we have there was a lot of I
guess additional questions and ideas
about how this could be applied so the
need to think of a flow between
researchers and people not as subjects
but as people we talked a lot about
leadership and the challenges between
what you'll have in leadership classes
that are in many ways talking about
these things and identity and valuing
people and then when that's actually put
into practice in business the same sort
of principles don't always apply and
that it is important really to think
about as we said group identity when
you're trying to institute
organizational change opportunities to
back to research opportunities to
connect with clients without overly
emphasizing the measurement so again
treating them as people not just data
points
we talked about some of the causes of
what was seen as at the the increase in
individualism and how that's reflected
in urban design and in our economics
dating back to the Industrial Revolution
and now we're starting to in some ways
see a bit of move a bit of a movement
back towards more social identity and
group concerns that were perhaps lost
for a period of time through the through
the 80s and 90s yeah think about it did
I miss anything anybody from the group
yeah somebody I didn't catch your name
she came in late but she made a really
good point about how we used to do
things more group based when we had less
resources and then when we have more
resources we don't but that's not good
so she I think unless I miss
representing her she basically said
there she is that it's a good thing that
times are getting tighter because it
will force us to go back to some of
these more effective / less expensive
group approaches to certain things yes
thank you
group five
thank you yeah Thank You Jerry Lynn we
our group didn't so much go through the
questions that were posed to us but just
started talking and so we spent quite a
bit of time talking about the needing to
address the how the dominant group
influences policy without and ascribing
needs and kind of creating approaches
with non dominant groups and so needing
to flip that around so that we are
respective of group identity and that
there is self-determination inside those
groups in terms of their own health and
development we talked about being able
to develop qualitative as well as that
we can't express our qualitative
outcomes without having quantitative
outcomes because that's where the money
lies but the importance of being able to
do that and recognizing identity inside
of those outcomes we talked about groups
changing throughout the lifespan so from
a student through a retiree that our
identities change as the result of where
where we are in our lifespan and we also
talked about ascribing not against not
thinking or paying attention to
populations and ascribing good things so
as an or what we think are good things
so as an example I'm Canadian Mental
Health Association and we one of our
service streams is providing housing and
we recently had a new apartment building
built and we are very excited to have a
community room in
building for our 27 tenants and that
room is essentially remained empty
because they are not that is not their
community their community is with other
groups outside of that building so it's
pretty expensive real estate we're still
trying to figure out a good way to use
it but I think it's a good thing for us
to think about when we are making plans
for others thank you thank you group
number six yeah my name is Kate and yeah
we talked about a lot of the the same
points that have been raised are already
by groups one to five but I think there
were about three things that we spent
our conversation we had quite an
eclectic group like most of you did
people from the museum field from the
municipal field from working with the
provincial government we were lucky to
have Robert join us from U of C so that
was that was great and interesting to
see that you know we had some of the
same questions and challenges so one of
the three things i wanted to mention is
that we really talked a lot about
shifting attitudes and shifting the way
we come at problems or issues or
challenges less from an individual point
of view and more within that holistic
sort of connection to community and so I
think that was in doing that we talked
about a lot of examples and it sort of
reflected the group around in in group 6
there we talked about the event in
public library and how they're
envisioning their role their own
identity in a different way and what
their role is to try to welcome everyone
and to make everyone feel a part of what
they do and how they're in fact
responding whether we call it action or
policy they're responding to new needs
and to new demands in the community in a
really creative innovative way we talked
also about someone mentioned to seniors
care home where they had talked about
something called butterfly homes where
they really engage the residents as they
wanted to in serving food
had the staff joined the residents to
eat and have meals so again challenging
that traditional stereotype of what a
seniors care home is and how it operates
so we talked about lots of those those
examples we also had quite a discussion
around the identity centered policies
and what that is but it means what it
could be I think a number of people felt
that we often over engineer solutions
when solutions can be simple can be
intuitive don't necessarily have to be
linear and don't have to be over
structured that that that's important
and someone mentioned in the field of
early childhood that they're working in
they said that we know that it's the
everyday interactions that are so
important it's not those structured
policy-driven kinds of actions and
programs that may have that lasting
input we really enjoyed having Robert
talk to us about about his work and his
involvement with the Autism Society and
what propelled him to join and become
involved in the autism society and how a
real a really negative reaction to the
workers that he and his family were
dealing with propelled him and many
other people to look for other solutions
and other groups and other identities so
although it was sort of a negative
origins of the story it ended up with a
really positive outcome and I think in
terms of we didn't have much time to
talk about how we take this back but i
think we all sort of thought that this
idea of the identity centered policies
and the shift in attitudes is something
we'll take back to the work we're doing
when we're looking for innovative new
solutions my group has anything else to
add
thank you let's circle back to our last
group number one Thanks yes a lot has
already been covered so I can I can be
really brief I think the general
consensus in our group is that it was
inspiring and validating without
necessarily being new it's that whole
preaching to the choir thing I think
which always happens but it was
inspiring in part because of the
spotlight that is being placed on social
connectedness has a basic health and
well-being issue we think that is
absolutely inspiring and we also talked
about and appreciated that there is
still a long way to go and the group
just wanted me to share this anecdote a
few years ago my research group was
involved in evaluating a parenting
training program in our Berta a study
involved about a thousand parents that
we got out and talked to and I guess
what was a little bit surprising is the
parents came back to us and quite
consistently with the same message and
that was oh yeah it was nice to learn
some skills that will help me manage my
child's behavior but what I really
valued was the opportunity to connect
with other mums the sense of belonging
that I came away with and so many of
those mums were were you know their
husbands were will you know maybe
working working on the oil fields and so
on and there's you know there's a real
issue with lots of temporary workers
moving in and out and the social
disconnection associated with that but
but I took that message to a senior
person in the ministry and you know the
message that I got back was you know the
government doesn't want to hear that
money is being wasted on these mums talk
chatting over coffee you know and you
know again it just seems to me how it
just reinforces for me how important
these that we keep put
a spotlight on how critical social
connection is and the informal learning
and so on that can take place through
those opportunities that we create and
following on from what what the previous
group was talking about yeah it's not
just about imposing or offering up
structured off-the-shelf solutions in
fact when it comes to social
connectedness that's probably impossible
but it is about creating opportunities
for that to emerge perhaps in a more
organic way and that's because social
identity has to be owned right by the
people themselves I'm not sure though if
other group members wanted to add
anything to that we're all good great
thank you David okay to wrap things up
just before lunch here I'd like to let
you know that after today's event there
will be a summary report produced that
will include some of the themes that we
heard from the day that will be
distributed to participants those who
registered as well as the presenter
slides and all of everything all of the
recording from the webcast and those
slides will all be on the CFR website as
well as the center's website at www and
details on future sessions with the
ideas exchange series are currently
being developed and the next event as
mentioned this morning will be held in
Vancouver in partnership with the bc
ministry of social development and
social innovation and bc partners for
social impact and in Toronto with the
United Way Toronto so I'd like to to
thank all of our speakers today so thank
you Alexander Frankel Catherine Martin
Robert Allen thank you very much and I'd
like to acknowledge the coordinating
committee that put this morning together
Rebecca Finley Robin black Adar Cathy
Scott Amy cook and
castor we'd also like to recognize our
suppliers here the venue the Chateau
lacombe psav our audio-visual support
and a squared communications for the
webcast and I'd like to invite everybody
to join us for lunch up in the swirling
restaurant on the 14th floor i believe
it is and just wanted to end with with
one thought from somebody that said this
in our group as we we thought about
children and reflected on children a
little bit today and he said children
like to play with others who are really
good at playing with them and I think
that's a neat way of thinking about
things and how we interact with other
people so thank you very much for
attending today